[Music]  [Applause]  elokar what are you  life before death storms strength before  weakness  journey before oh uh oh  caledon what are you doing here pal how  could you  kill him i just well you know been on my  mind for a while and he kind of deserves  it so  you know you like betrayed me right oh  well  yeah me killing ello carp that's  in the past now you just killed he's  still on the ground  caledon i know you love me oh okay you  know what just stop  you can't keep getting inside of my  brain i haven't been  a great friend to you i love you bro  i love you i love you bro you know okay  bridge four bridge four all right you  know what just  why don't you just leave yeah i should  just go guys  i'll go i'll come see ya  you